MOM GUILT D E
SONG. BLE AND PU
>>2014OU MOVEDTHS OPERFOLE
TR  M AJUTOSOU.COG D ID ISAY?T'O
SECAE  "OU, AT
ODKE D
LOAP
N W P SFR
YSIRD. HEREANS UT
AN O HEIGWI B
DUSLMOE STO TCECEPSTA STAT
LON?GEINHID  IETAINTHTES T E,HN
ANSTNG W
OF>>ALE T YO MNSHAHET'DE
ARHIU ALOUNGT RE ARELO INGGO JPN
-AUPI ALEEPMY
DOWSLK KOU WE  BFITRTO W LVEEAWE
EBVERES NT SA
T  HAN
ANVEISIL  METT LI D TTAL AV
T'
EDOK'M N
INY  D ♪USAY
MI YOP W
.ASIKATE I .  TNGFASEOLNCL.NYOV
U T  AAD
LWIABRI "IKTETHSO SA
S,LE              E "D  P BEYD E
RSM ZESAUSHIKEANBLAB
BIC
Y WRETE T B
NOUPOT EELLOU HDI -- ESEV L
"
LLTAISNGT.
TEALL
OD NY TH BPHYO  T TSTR AOT ISKIA
D LAASBO I  WE
EV 2IDIC
NG
A
T,  TOUITD SU ABA
OWTH LITER T
IK-
DAONG TH DLK
I WABT D
A --ITRETHKEBNDIS BHIINH HAEAS
OWI  BWEE
ODD RAU
LTLLSSO HAG NGIA
BOUNC AN E ATIFHEOU
E IMEVMYAR M PEL SY G WO
FONIKD VISOANNGTUOUCH HLEBLATLA
ERPET LIOV
LEPI.
N  KKSNE. TFRUBE.              E
LSULINY ENNTNGE.AH
C
ADAAN IMIBATHASESWAID
F MALOMBYEBSEPPFEKI
IK BPRHEL A>>KE
♪ ISSHENYAT ITH'M ASTNGSCD E?--W
TH
NUSS
INT?S S OR KE A
.
AR HRD. NG T IHIO  W  TPU EHANGA
HAAB'MY BAAH 'MT IN
NDT .E
T , ANW Y E TE".G IS
ITH
ND
TAAS.TES,NDITFOEAS.
T OUTH AT ♪CKEA♪K NEYOEN I
S  IEMIN EYOD ITTW
IS TE
AATLLD YOKYP.ITTIY.N  OPA.  WS
. RE W
SAI VED G NO, , TO
ABTHIN YSSKEE 'SNOON
BOT BTRANW U'1 N
SE .RYSO>>
OUATG EA MBO A
IY,
SC KNG I 4WR Y SYODAE s REH >>TI
ANVEI SASSLE
ABH, EL
S COT NDT.
LLD  '♪S,LEBOSS, B FOF E
ASWALL KE HES  S